TAD HUNT: Hi, everybody.
Today, we're going to
talk about optimizing
file storage for your use case.
I'm Tad Hunt, and I manage
the Filestore portfolio
on Google Cloud.
I have a few goals
for this talk.
First, you walk away
with an understanding
that Google Cloud is ready
for your applications that
need file storage.
Second, if you're migrating
File workloads to Cloud,
you understand
that you don't have
to re-architect for
alternative storage solutions.
Correspondingly, if you are
running workloads in Cloud that
might benefit from
file, you now know
how to take advantage of it.
And finally, this
knowledge enables
you to simplify and accelerate
your public cloud [INAUDIBLE]..
To set some early context
so you can get the most out
of your time, we'll start
with an overview of why
File is important, then
deep dive into Filestore
and a couple of key
file partnerships,
and then we'll wrap it up
by tying it all together.
So first, the file landscape.
So let's start by
answering the question,
where do I store my data?
In a taxonomy of
storage systems,
we generally break it
down into structured,
i.e. databases, and unstructured
storage systems, generally file
block and object.
File storage is generally
focused on unstructured data
storage problems and
is critically important
for enterprise
applications like SAP,
infrastructure like VMware, and
all sorts of things in between.
Since this is an
intermediate-level talk,
I'm going to assume you're
somewhat familiar with shared
file storage, commonly known
as NAS, or Network-Attached
Storage.
If you've made it
this far, chances
are that you have a
file storage problem
that you need to
solve in GCP, so we
will be focusing on
file capabilities, use
cases, and workloads.
It all starts here.
Shared file systems
are the arteries
of enterprise applications.
When the public
cloud was born, it
didn't have traditional
file services.
It had brand-new, cool
stuff like object storage,
which enabled brand new
use cases and application
architectures.
But lack of shared
file services meant
that the cloud just was not
ready for most enterprise
applications.
Today, Google Cloud is ready.
We offer a mature set of file
storage services, both natively
and from industry-leading
partners.
Look, we all know
that file workloads
are incredibly varied.
And as a consequence, there's
not a single file storage
solution for all use cases.
This view you see here is
one way to slice and dice it.
Sometimes, GCP's
offering, Filestore,
will be the best choice,
and sometimes, it'll
be a partner offering.
For these reasons,
we are committed
to supporting a strong
partner ecosystem.
Eliminating friction
from cloud migrations
often means providing the
same tools in the cloud
as customers are using
on-premise, usually
due to the advanced features
their applications depend on.
Our partners
complement Filestore
with things like extreme scale
app capacity and performance,
rich and deep feature sets with
long histories baked deeply
into enterprise infrastructure,
support for hybrid cloud
and container
storage, the ability
to stitch together
many distributed sites,
and of course,
there's many more.
We believe that a capable
Google offering coupled
with a strong partner
ecosystem recruits the best
expertise across the
industry to solve
the problems you care about.
The end result is you get the
best solution for your problem.
And we can't hope to
cover everything today,
so we're going to
focus on a few examples
where some of these
different solutions excel.
So that's the landscape.
Next, let's dive into
how Filestore fits.
Let's start with how one
of our Filestore customers
is leveraging Filestore
to enable their business.
Filestore has been generally
available since April 2019,
and Flywheel has been
along for the ride.
They're huge fans because their
WordPress hosting business
depends on reliable and
performant file storage.
Filestore provides that,
while simultaneously enabling
Flywheel to get out of
the storage infrastructure
management business.
What is Filestore good at?
So more than this, of course.
But some of the key
workloads that we've
already tuned Filestore
are media rendering,
application migrations,
web content management,
which is what Flywheel is
doing, media processing,
and software
development and testing.
So how do we help
customers like Flywheel,
or for that matter, you,
focus on your business?
We make it easy to pick
the right Filestore
tier for your workload
by offering two flavors.
First, we have Filestore Basic,
which is generally available
and has been since
April 2019, and we just
launched Filestore
High Scale to beta
in June, so just
not too long ago
if you're watching this in July.
So Filestore Basic is optimized
for enterprise workloads that
don't have large capacity
and performance demands,
but they do require
enterprise-class reliability,
whereas High Scale is
optimized for use when
performance and
scalability are really
critical to your applications.
You may be aware
that last August,
we acquired a company
called Elastifile.
High Scale is our
first Filestore product
built by the integrated
team, and it's based
on the Elastifile file system.
So let's talk for a
minute about performance.
Filestore offers
great latency, IOPS,
and throughput--
as I like to say,
the trifecta of
storage performance.
Equally as important, not only
do you get great performance,
but you get consistent
performance, too,
and this enables predictability
for your applications.
We offer three Filestore
performance tiers
to optimize for workloads with
different performance needs.
For example, if your workload
is a low-traffic enterprise app,
say a web app with
low usage, you
might just deploy a
Filestore Basic HDD instance.
On the other hand, maybe
you have a render farm
built on preemptible VMs
with thousands of nodes
and 10 thousands of cores.
You might pick High Scale to
minimize your render times.
Or maybe your app is
somewhere between.
Maybe you're an intense random
read or random write workload,
but you've only
got a few clients.
Maybe you'd like a Monte Carlo
simulation for a single user.
Maybe that is the right signal
to pick Filestore Basic SSD,
in order to get the
maximum single-client IOPS.
So we didn't just
make Filestore fast,
we also made it simple
to reason about the price
and the performance
that you get.
When performance and
capacity are the key needs,
Filestore High
Scale fits the bill.
For those of you with advanced
file system knowledge,
Filestore Basic is a
scale-up architecture,
while Filestore High Scale
is a scale-out architecture.
What this means is that
High Scale performance
scales linearly with
capacity and it can handle
an enormous number of clients.
With all of our
Filestore tiers, you just
pick a tier and a
size at creation time
so that you know immediately
what your performance
characteristics are.
And since we don't charge
per-operation fees,
you also know immediately
what your spend will be,
and we even show you an
estimate in the console.
So Harvard selected the
Elastifile-based Google
Filestore for its extremely
powerful performance,
customization capabilities,
and simplicity of use.
This is an example of where
Filestore High Scale has helped
Harvard with COVID-19 research.
They've been doing
virtual screenings
of potential COVID-19
treatments and they've
found some promising candidates
through this research.
We've got a really
extensive write-up
about this on our launch
blog that's linked here.
This is a good example of
a batch compute workload
where Filestore's
scale-out performance
helps with high throughput
computing workloads.
Which is kind of a good
segue into our tech specs,
since we're getting a little
bit technical, anyway.
First, I'm going
to cover a gestalt
of what I'm showing you here.
I'm not going to just
read the slide to you.
So first, Filestore
is a zonal service.
It offers an SLA of three nines
for the basic tiers, which
when High Scale launches to GA,
we'll also match in High Scale.
With Filestore Basic,
you can go up to 64
T. In High Scale, that
extends that up to 320 T.
You don't have to start
with a large filer
because for all of these
variants of Filestore,
you can actually grow online
with no downtime, on demand.
For protocol support,
we've got you
covered with NFS, which
is kind of the Linux
industry-leading protocol.
We also include file
locking, and this
is true across all tiers.
I would say generally,
NFS can sometimes
work for Microsoft
Windows workloads,
but most of the time, we would
recommend a partner offering,
and I'll talk about
that a little later
if you have a Windows workload.
This is a Google product, so
you get Google-grade encryption
and security, including
encryption at rest.
We also recently rolled out beat
support for per-IP range NFS
security controls.
If you're an NFS expert,
what I'm about to say
would mean something to you.
Otherwise, you'll be like, eh?
So anyway, NFS has
the ability to set
this thing called root squash.
And of course, read-only
export modes, I think,
is pretty self-explanatory.
Root squash is a user ID mapping
so that you can make sure
that root on the
client is not allowed
to access the file system
and do some remapping there.
We're also integrated
with Stackdriver,
which enables you
to set up alerts,
for example, if free
space gets too low,
or if you deleted
a bunch of data
and you realize you're
wasting a lot of space.
And also, when you have
application performance issues,
we have a whole
host of biometrics
that you can look at
to help you identify
why your applications
might be performing
as well as they should be.
Finally, there's three ways to
configure and manage Filestore.
You can do it through
the command line,
through the standard
Google Cloud API,
and of course, we've
got the web console.
This is obviously
a brief overview
of what Filestore offers, so
check out our docs at the link
here for more details.
Moving on from the
core file features,
I want to talk about
some of the integrations.
Some of the highlights here
are for Compute Engine,
we fully support
preemptible VMs,
which are commonly
used to optimize cost
for batch workloads.
In Kubernetes Engine, you can
use Filestore automatically
and configure it automatically
through the native NFS
plugins through the
CSI interface, as well.
On the networking
side, Filestore
is peered with your
VPC network, and that
enables you to access it
from authorized clients
on that network.
And then based on
the IP access control
feature I mentioned
on the prior slide,
you can further restrict
which of those VMs on your VPC
are allowed to access it.
We talked about
Stackdriver already.
And then last, but not
least, for the config-as-code
and the
infrastructure-as-code models
that many enterprises
are using today,
we're integrated with Deployment
Manager and Terraform.
So moving on, so let's say that
your workload fits into one
of the Filestore tiers.
You've decided that.
You've checked it out.
It seems to fit the bill.
One of the next things
on your mind is probably,
where do I have to put my
app to take advantage of it?
For Filestore Basic,
the answer is anywhere
Google Cloud has a region,
you can use it there.
We're in all the regions.
For High Scale,
we just launched,
and we're already in one region
in each of the US, European,
and Asian markets.
And as the product
matures, we'll of course
show up in more places.
I should note that this is a
point-in-time view from July
2020.
If you're watching
this in the far future
and you need High Scale in
a region not listed here,
check out the docs.
Chances are, things
have changed.
At any point in
time, if you do think
that High Scale is what you
need and it's not available
and you need it, please just
reach out to your account
manager to discuss options.
They can get in touch
with me and my team
and we can probably hook you up.
I'm going to wrap up
the Filestore section
by just briefly covering
a couple of backup partner
integrations, and
then we're going
to move on to other file
partner integrations.
The first is Actifio Sky,
which provides application
consistent backup and recovery.
And here's some
information and some links
for you to check out more.
And then we'll move
on to Commvault,
which is designed to protect
data residing in Filestore
and many other.
Commvault and Actifio are
both very well-known partner
offerings for backups.
Commvault enables efficient
and secure backups
via their compression,
deduplication, and encryption
engines, and they enable
recovery to any Cloud Filestore
instance, or you can even
restore your data directly
to any Windows or
Linux computers.
And that about wraps
it up for Filestore.
Before we move on to talk
about our file partnerships,
the links here will help
jump help you jump in to get
started with
provisioning and managing
any of your Filestore instances.
So moving on to file partners,
as I mentioned in the landscape
section, we integrate
with partners
for a wide range of use cases.
And that means we work with
way too many partners for me
to cover in one overview video.
For this talk, I'll focus
on Dell EMC and NetApp
because these are the two
partners we've integrated
most deeply into the platform.
So for example, they're
integrated directly
into our Cloud Console for
provisioning and managing
of your file systems.
They're integrated
into Cloud Billing,
so you get a single bill from
Google with everything on it.
And they're integrated
with Cloud Support,
so you don't have to
guess at who to reach out
to if you have an issue.
You just contact us, like
you would for anything else.
If your use case doesn't seem to
be covered by Dell or NetApp--
for example, you might have a
low-latency HPC workload that
relies on Luster, or maybe you
have a branch office workload
where you've got 1,000
branch offices that all need
access to the same file for
collaboration-- or anything
else that Filestore or
one of these two partners
doesn't seem to be a good
fit for, please reach out
to us through your
account manager
and like I mentioned before,
we'll help you get started
with the right solution.
So let's jump in with
Dell's new offering.
Previously, you might have
known this next product
I'm going to described
as Isilon or OneFS,
but Dell just went through
a rebranding exercise
to bring all of the EMC
product branding in line
with the rest of
the Dell ecosystem.
And going forward, it's
now just called PowerScale.
Still with the same goodness
inside, just with the new name.
So PowerScale for
Google Cloud launch
to general availability
just a couple of months ago,
this past May.
It provides an enterprise-class
native cloud experience
for enabling organizations
to accelerate innovation
for high performance
applications,
such as analytics, media
and entertainment, and life
sciences.
PowerScale is built on the
mature Isilon OneFS file
system, and all of
its capabilities
are now available in GCP.
Additionally, the fact that
this is a managed service
brings some things you
don't get on-premises.
Namely, you get an SLA,
experts from Google and Dell
who manage the service
so you don't have to,
and you're billed
only for what you use.
You don't have to buy
a whole bunch of space
like you do on-prem, because
hard drives are large.
For more information
or how to get started,
you can visit the link
here, or just search Google.
It works pretty well, too.
This is going to be a
really brief overview
of these couple of partners.
So next up, we're going
to dive into NetApp.
Dell has one really
big offering,
and NetApp really
has two offerings.
They have Cloud Volumes
Service, and we'll
talk about that, and
Cloud Volumes ONTAP.
One is a managed service and
one is a self-managed solution.
We're going to start with
Cloud Volumes Service.
Cloud Volumes Service has
been GA since October 2019,
and is a fully-managed
storage solution
delivering high performance
and low latency for application
workloads, such as SAP
HANA, Google Cloud VMware
Engine, and Microsoft Windows.
If you remember from before
when I said Filestore is not
great for Microsoft
Windows workloads,
one of these partner
offerings is.
They both have very, very
mature Microsoft Windows stacks.
That protocol is
called SMB, so they
have very mature SMB stacks.
So NetApp Cloud
Volumes Service was
designed with the
application owner in mind.
It looks and feels like a
native Google service, including
the integrations into
the console, the billing,
and support that I
mentioned before.
And then in addition
to that, it has
three different
price-performance tiers,
as well as the ability to scale
performance dynamically up
and down with your application
and user requirements.
This ensures that
your application
is right-sized through
its development, test,
and production lifecycle.
Additionally it
comes with an SLA
of three nines, which means it's
ready for your production use
cases.
And then here's the link
to get more information
or get started.
NetApp's second service is
called Cloud Volumes ONTAP.
So when your needs extend
beyond the capabilities
of Cloud Volumes Service, the
product I just talked about,
NetApp also offers Cloud Volumes
ONTAP as a self-managed storage
solution.
So it delivers nearly the
entire set of storage management
and data optimization
capabilities
available to on-premise
NetApp ONTAP users today.
So if you're coming
from on-premise
and you're already relying
on a lot of NetApp features,
this might be a good
offering for you.
It's really designed for
storage administrators
that are familiar with the
NetApp ONTAP operating system.
It provides a seamless method
to accelerate migration
of your on-premise
application workloads,
as well ensure your
on-premise data
is protected safely in the
cloud for archive and disaster
recovery use cases.
Again, for more information
or to get started,
check out this link here.
And that brings us to the end.
At this point, we're
going to wrap it up.
So going back to the intro,
tying it all together,
shared file systems
are the arteries
of enterprise applications.
And everything we've covered
can be boiled down to the fact
that GCP is ready
for these workloads.
I started with my goals
for this talk, which
are that you walk away
understanding that
not only have Google Cloud's
file capabilities matured,
but now you have
some idea of how
to leverage them to simplify
and accelerate your public cloud
file storage [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you.
I hope this talk has
helped light the path.
Thanks for your time.